so guys we're here today because we're
going to talk about the new movie Bros
do you know anything about it sunny no I
know nothing about it nothing okay well
good because actually you haven't seen
the trailer yet either I know that the
movie is a romantic comedy just hit uh
opened up last weekend and it is about
it's but it's a gay romantic comedy and
it's about two games you know I
I know you've been waiting and so it
it's all over the news because it
flopped at the box office it had a 25
million dollar budget it did under five
million dollars at the box office not to
worry if you care because it'll it'll
end up on streaming services making them
probably making money like almost even
shitty films do good thing we're giving
them some free promotion yeah well you
know what it's it it is an important
conversation culturally because there's
opinions flying over on why it flops
like the New York Times gave a bunch of
reasons but and said it is in part based
on homophobia which is I think idiotic
you know because we're not homophobic
we're just [ __ ] phobic in America
that's what I think I have a real I know
the real reason I think why this movie
flopped so I want to just take a second
and show Sunny the trailer and see what
he thinks hey guys it's Bobby Lieber
coming to you from the future home of
the lgbtq plus Museum everyone is really
excited and totally getting along
this happens to be bisexual awareness
week and no one has acknowledged it
lesbian history month was in March
and Mark damn thing of course of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week
so what's happening didn't you guys have
an announcement this is a little
unexpected but we are in a throuple
situation you're in a throttle I'd
rather die than watch this
no wonder they this didn't someone
funded 25 million dollars to this [ __ ]
he usually sounds gayer too and all his
other stuff he's straight now I love my
life I love my freedom I love my
Independence that's kind of sad that I
don't want to be in a throuple I don't
even want to be in a couple
I had sex with that 65 year old Jesus
he's ripped I don't know it's like they
injected steroids into Dumbledore
oh my God that's Aaron he's very hot
gay guys are so stupid I know but we've
been smart enough to Brand ourselves as
being smart it's our little secret
you met a guy I don't think I'm his type
he's like gay Tom Brady what are you
into one of these ripped idiots with no
opinions no I'd like someone who's
physically very frail and won't stop
talking and I bet he's as intimidated by
you as you are by him I'm down for
whatever yeah I can do whenever and I
can do whatever cool Whatever Whenever
GIF of Michael Scott dancing office GIF
this person isn't gay
[Music]
I need you to be honest with me you like
the growing me
all right I just hate couple [ __ ] to
begin with today is National boyfriends
day and all I see on Instagram is
[ __ ] girls posting their stupid
boyfriends I don't give a [ __ ] is that
just a coincidence I love that okay it's
more than halfway through come on and
it's just all like with me please stay
with me it's all jokes that you know
they've wrote in a uh a stupid little
rectangular room all sitting around the
table like I don't even know explain it
I'll collect your boys oh that's what
you like it's just so cliche
that's cool
[Music]
I just have a pride party and you're
both too old to be in the pool
please leave
people are threatening to boycott the
museum you can't say Lincoln was gay if
we don't do we're letting the
heterosexual terrorists win there are
trans terrorists too Caitlyn Jenner
so different for me you're very intense
I like to keep things chill I can be
chill just like a manly man what's up
what's up I got you yeah
bro what is going on with you my whole
life I prided myself on being
self-reliant but this guy has gone into
my head
maybe you both bottoms and that's a
problem
[Music]
this sex was more fun when straight
people were uncomfortable with it
[Music]
oh my god do you guys remember straight
people yeah they had a nice run
[Music]
lighten up sunny boy personally I know I
know that this just hurts you it's just
four it's just so forced it's so forced
that why would you want to how could you
anybody want to watch that [ __ ] it's the
same with straight people too like you
just said like anything that's just so
shoved down your throat those cliche ass
jokes it's the same jokes that they make
in other movies they just twist it a
little bit and throw it in this [ __ ] and
make it yeah it's the same jokes it's
you're right you're right who directed
that I bet you I could okay let's find
out
Forgetting Sarah Marshall get him to the
creek okay those are good movies they're
funny those are those are actual it's
the same feel though it's just it's just
gay now like if they're and I don't know
it's it's all just the same [ __ ] yep I
don't like watching movies like that
those are comedies get them to the Greek
and Forgetting Sarah Marshall are really
funny movies okay so you you know I know
you're real serious and stuff but you
gotta calm down a little I personally
look at that and maybe it's my age maybe
it's because I grew up in New York City
like I grew up in Brooklyn and we were
just around all kinds of different
people all the time I personally thought
that trailer was amusing and I'd be
happy to watch it really yeah yeah I
want to see this movie not to mention
that the like the second gay lead in the
movie is like drop dead gorgeous and
sorry women don't care if a guy is gay
we can look at him and be like holy hell
who made that okay that's a whole other
thing but here's where there's here's
here's where there's actual problems and
something to something to think about so
the the the the lead the less hot lead
in the in the movie a guy named Billy
Eichner he's not helping okay so he
tweeted yesterday about the terrible box
office returns that's just the world we
live in unfortunately even with glowing
reviews great Rotten Tomatoes scores and
a cinema score Etc straight people
especially in certain parts of the
countries just didn't show up for Bros
and that's disappointing oh I'm sorry
we'll make a few more Millions you know
I just watched bullet train a couple
months ago and leaving the theater I was
like wow that movie was amazing like
this might be one of my favorite movies
you know I was a little banged up
watching it but I thought it was really
good at the time and then it didn't get
any good reviews and nobody else I knew
watched it did I go out there
complaining about the system and how you
didn't get the recognition it deserved
or yeah you're making a really good
point so the rest of his thing is
everyone who isn't home isn't a
homophobic we're a homophobic weirdo
should go see Bros tonight okay you're
not helping you're you're not helping
your cause one you're in business so
don't go insult the people that didn't
shop at your business okay it's stupid
it's bad business it's not smart first
of all second of all if you really care
about the LGBT community and you really
believe that this movie is gonna help
you know move acceptance forward
whatever Twisted logic he has in his
head extend an olive branch to people
who didn't who didn't come to see your
movie don't call them weirdos don't call
them names they're homophobic no we're
not homophobic like I said we're just
sick of [ __ ] and here's the real
reason I think this movie completely
[ __ ] back when slavery still a thing
Abraham Lincoln where are you going
where am I going don't you want to know
now Abraham Lincoln
said and I'm gonna power
part of it is
Lim must be protected yet often a limb
must be amputated to Save a Life what he
meant by that is that in order to
protect and save the Constitution and
the Democracy the Republic rather that
we had to amputate slavery in order to
preserve the true nature of the
Constitution and the true essence of it
and what's happening with a movie like
this you're going to wonder yeah how did
I make this leap is because the
lgbtqia plus needs to separate because
you have LGB lesbians gays bisexuals
over here living normal lives just going
about their business living and then
you've got that t
lgbtqia plus acting like a bunch of
[ __ ] lunatics getting into schools
doing drag density drag shows at [ __ ]
preschools and getting into teenagers
heads uncomfortable teenage girls who
don't like it being in puberty and
they're like well that's because you
really might be trans and giving them
out and they're all turning into lunatic
turning into lunatic and going off the
[ __ ] rails okay off the rails so now
when you have something that might be in
a music gay rom-com that most mainstream
Americans would enjoy those who like
rom-coms because again we're not
normally rom-com fans you [ __ ]
attached all this lunacy to it how are
you supposed to how are you supposed to
succeed everyone's sick of it enough the
lgbs need to step away and say you know
what t q i A's plus whatever you are a
bunch of freaks go make your own [ __ ]
club because you're [ __ ] hurting us
am I wronged I don't know it's your
opinion yeah I I think that like like I
said it's just when they're non-stop
shoving it down your throat it's fine
like when this guy does the Billy on the
Street videos I think they're funny and
it's not because he's shoving the fact
that he's gay down your throat he's
acting more gay like he you know when
he's normally talking he actually sounds
like he is gay but he's just being
himself and he's being funny and the
other [ __ ] where it's just so it's
forcing it remember straight people it's
just it's all just it's jokes it's jokes
but it's not it's just it's I don't like
that [ __ ] it's Billy Eichner and this is
funnier dies Billy on the Street a music
and pop culture game show now before we
get to this week's three round game
where's this guy before the movie Bros
for a dollar here we get missed are you
jealous of Beyonce's success
no I don't believe you
uh I wouldn't believe me either okay
are you having a good day I am are you I
am having a good day so he's talking
like more like himself he actually
sounds gay here or am I even allowed to
say that I don't care he does but it's
not being shoved down your throat and
it's there's it doesn't feel like
they're trying to be an agenda pushed
onto you you know what I mean not
certainly not in this video yeah I think
that these are funny I just don't like
that other [ __ ] where it's
yeah again I don't know that's just my
thoughts again I also don't like
straight rom-coms they have ruined it
for gay people by attaching because
again watch Brokeback Mountain watch
Grace and Frankie huge Hits Huge hits
we're not homophobic we're crazy phobic
we're done with the [ __ ] as a nation
all right that's it I say all this stuff
on my Twitter account do you follow me
on Twitter I don't know I don't have any
followers on Twitter I talk to myself
yeah you should could you at least
follow me on there maybe Sunny no he's
gonna I'm gonna break into his phone
well you're gonna tell them your Twitter
yeah it's at mother Sunny
m-o-t-h-a-s-o-n mothers mother Sunny you
don't why don't you just use the same
tag on all of them
that's the one they gave me you can
change your tag can you all right well
somebody's gonna fix it but this is just
this mom's [ __ ] all right are you done
are you done yeah I'm good
thank you
[Music]